this matters now to Howard Ward he's
chief investment officer of growth
equities at gamco he's been rewarded
with patients on Apple free cash flow
wins particularly when the cash flow
goes back to shareholders let's review
you had a belief in the persistency of
their product is a success of Apple a
product success or is it a financial
success well Tom the financials has sex
success made possible by the product
success success the DL the iphone as far
and away exceeded all expectations and
you know this is a stock that is now up
a hundred percent over the last two
years two years ago it was being
criticized for lack of innovation and
Tim Cook was being criticized for not
being steve jobs which of course he
isn't that's not all bad but now we see
company that's flourishing iphone 6 and
6 plus huge success revenues of nearly
200 billion dollars right the iphone
sixty percent of the revenues seventy
percent of the is it is it a blue chip
stock that brendan Greeley's mother can
buy i certainly think so now of course
the big mispricing is over and so the
big outperformance is largely behind us
no I do think I love that will trip up
the script here what is the bright guy
like you do your the courage to buy it
in 09 and 10 that's miss performance at
valuation Delta's gone what is a pro do
now well Tom yeah I think that the stock
will get up into the 140s in this sort
of positive environment that I foresee
which would get you close to a market
multiple on on next year's earnings for
apples to below the market multiple but
I do believe in the law of large numbers
and I am very concerned about the
comparisons not this year but next year
okay take it over to the broader market
then we've had a five-year bull market
things are great 2100 SPX 18,000 Dow do
you lighten up here or do you have that
confidence that you had three years ago
now you know the economy is doing very
well as Michelle alluded to minute ago
the last three months of payroll gains
have been the strongest in 17 years we
generated three million jobs last year
that's the best in 15 years consumer
confidence surveys there are three of
them ones that wanted the Michigan ones
at an 11-year high the other two are at
seven year highs GDP growth this year I
think will exceed three percent trend
line growth for LG TPS
point where is the courage right now
where does Howard warden encouraging
guts to step into the market now would
sector well I think the important thing
is to be invested and then what you're
invested I think you would need to look
for better values and some of the more
economically sensitive areas of the
market because the staples and health
care well I mean I mean I mean you drove
it because the time Warren Buffett
selling ExxonMobil today does that mean
Howard word buys well i'm not sure if
warren buffett sold out or one of his
lieutenants sold that and and and and
they didn't own it all that long so you
know i don't know what all prices are
going to do I have three oil holdings I
think I'd rather be a buyer of some oil
stocks today oil stocks today should not
reflect today's oil prices they should
reflect the theoretical average price of
crude / let's say the next 10 or 20
years you're calling her and I think
it's going to be higher absolutely
brother Howard ward with gamco on where
to find value maybe we'll buy those
shares from mr. Buffett